I uh I got stuck in the Vegas strip on
New Year's one time in the strip like
walking in the street yeah at New Year's
I was trying to get to my friends and I
took like a wrong way to walk and
there's literally there was a million
people you're stuck there was a million
people in the street nowhere to walk
everybody drinking those huge [__]
[__] yeah yes dude one guy was
running around he had this big thing and
for like a buck he put it around your
waist you could piss into it dude that's
smart that's really smart business out
of the blue this saw poop on the Strip
really guy was pooping on the trip dude
I saw a guy in India one time pooping
get hit by a [__] taxi mid poop yeah
did he live I don't know bro I don't
stay around after that yeah you got to
go I was cruising bro yeah there was a
lot of racism dude I remember one time
so I was friends with this kid named
Devon deu cuz I actually really joined
black Humanity for a while when I was
young you know really what with black
Humanity well just like I used to ride
my bike to school right cuz I lived in
this poor neighborhood and I didn't want
to get on the bus and kids see where I
was from I didn't want to get off the
POR bus at school so I would ride my
bike to school and it was about 5 miles
right and this was like in Middle School
you know so like but I'd go through the
black neighborhood you know like cuz our
neighborhood was white and black and
white at one end black at the other end
so I'd go through there and a lot of the
blacks would get on my bike you know and
they honestly used to call me the [__]
bus is what they would call me and they
would be like the [__] buses here and
they would all get like three or four of
them would get on my bike and be on my
shoulders and sitting on the front tall
blacks too like this one kid named
Jonathan Smith this kid had to be I
swear to God he was nine feet tall man
and he [__] made me ride him I
literally remember the back tire would
he was so [__] heavy the back tire of
my bike would come up which made me
wonder how's this bike even have any
traction on the road and I didn't call
myself the [__] bus that's what they
called me we had one Mexican kid that
showed up on our time we didn't have any
Spanish people we had one Mexican kid
let me think about what this kid's name
was I think it was Nick right and uh I
remember we we all had uh science class
and um oh actually in science class had
these hamsters you could play with until
the second bell rang or whatever then
you had to give you know put them in the
cage and everybody could then we would
do learning you know and this [__]
one time they had this hamster right
Superman we named him and uh and I was
holding him in this [__] big
sweatshirt I had right and after class
uh I forgot he was in there he fell
asleep in a little pocket right where
you put your hands right so after class
I just throw my book bag I'm running
next know get in a fight with two
brothers right get beat up pretty good
and one of them had [__] killed this
hamster that was still in this pouch he
[__] punched it so I never had it
like sometimes I'll be [__] I'm not
even joking bro I'll have dreams where I
feel like I had an
abortion yeah oh I was at a funeral one
time and the kid was yeah it was like a
like a 22y old dude he's getting buried
and uh his stepdad was like Sent send
him he sent it yeah yeah I was like damn
bro [__] that funeral was probably lit I
was like [__] turn up dude dude I was
at a funeral one time um and they uh the
DJ or whatever had like a stroke or
something in there dude and he like when
he hit the machine it played like a
Nelly song in the [__] uh in the uh
service you know it was that song like
apple bottom je you know what I'm
talking about that's low by T P oh sorry
so that's what it was it was yeah so
everybody's just sitting there and
people's crying and stuff and [__]
Randall's dead dude and every suddenly
you just hear [__] and people were
like what's going on and people were
like yelling like kind of pointing over
at that area and the guy in there I mean
it's sad but he'd had a stroke you know
and he like yeah cuz he was just you
know running the I guess had an electric
organ or whatever you know but that's I
don't know God sometimes like has like
funny stuff he does dude we had this kid
in our in my neighborhood named Robert
and he was like he thought he was twins
that never got separated right and so
yeah when he would talk he would say
something and then under his breath he
would say it again say it
again like that oh it never ended never
ended and it [__] scared the [__] out of
everybody bro and he could not stop
doing it doing it like an echo yeah wow
and you'd ask him why he didn't he said
he was there was twins inside of him and
one of them never got out that's so
funny wow they had a deaf kid in our
town and some kids beat him up one time
for doing bad magic cuz he was always
doing all of this you know the sign
language but you know he never pulled
out a quarter never pulled out a dove
and people beat his ass because they
thought he was doing bad magic yeah like
we had a bus driver dude he picked us up
one day and he even take us to [__]
school bro this dude Milford he just
drove us around and about 30 minutes
into it we're like [__] we ain't even
going to school bro we just on Tak y to
do something weird that's what he about
take no he was just driving I think he's
trying to stay away from his wife really
and uh I think he why not just take
y'all to school and then he D it wasn't
on his mind man he had different [__] on
his mind and look his name is Milford
his name is Milford bro sound Milford
[__] well most of my audience knows I
grew up when they had this boy down the
street for me this kid Mario and he in
order to hang out with them he made he a
brother Nam Luigi no he didn't dude no
and we going to leave that joke in um
but he would [__] in his own yard and
make me bury it in order to be able to
hang out with him right and you were his
poop [__] I wasn't a poop [__] I was a
young man and I was why would you bury
another man's poop if he asked you to do
it
what was the benefit cuz he was a tough
kid and there was otherwise to whoop
your ass yeah there was no real way to
hang out you so you were a poop [__] I
wasn't a poop [__] I was a guy who
would you know bury a man's poop
otherwise he' beat you up I would say I
worked in like janitorial services I
would say that you didn't get paid
though I you didn't really work you were
doing an internship in janitorial
service I didn't I got paid in the fact
that we got to you know be around each
other were you a poop [__] intern and
enjoying each other's company no I was
first in line Apprentice yeah you an
apprentice I was more of I would say
were there other people that buried his
poop there were not that I knew of you
were the key poop Bearer I would say
yeah you were Tip Top well I was that's
kind of privilege at that point I would
say I was a colon concierge that's what
I would say col concierge ah so this guy
was an excrement excavator go dude well
this guy was [__] and I'd have to hide
it in his yard right what his parents
ever did his parents ever know that he
was they had to have known dude his
mother was a librarian smart you know
and so she had to have known there's no
way you bury 200 of some guy's poops in
their own yard that trickle down you
think that his father did that you think
he learned that from his parents I'll
say this they had one of the best
Gardens anywhere in town I will say that
bro rose bushes 30 feet high bro
encapsulating the house dude just all
that oh that young lier bro in the in
the [__] ground well so here's what
happened was eventually and then he
would let me hang out with him dude this
boy Mario rafino and then he ended up
dying he ate a bunch of pills and drove
a boat into an embankment and here's the
thing on purpose was he [__] up was
mdle the night mle the night in a speed
boat and hit the side of an interstate
like one of those posts that goes down
the water yeah [__] he was high as [__]
I don't know if he was but he was always
he had a he had that vigilante in him
you know he own a boat these people had
some money to own a boat it was like a
boat that you would fish out of you uh
like yeah a little little tiny little
fish boat yeah and some of the fish
would get in and they be like I'm not
staying in this boat you know and jump
back in the water yeah the fish knew
better Mario's boat flop right back out
but and I wrote I remember I wrote his
parents a letter when that happened and
told them about that about that
experience about about him pooping in
the yard and me burying it yeah they
didn't write you back hundreds of times
they never wrote me back I I feel like
that letter might be framed at their
house and I wanted to be a Paul Bear I
remember and I cuz in my mind I wanted
to put him in the ground one last time
[Laughter]
that that's cold that's true story man
you know I knew dude I mean you know I
grew up around some [__] real crazy
poor white people you know the dude no
AR they had a dude in our town no arms
used to [__] fight everybody you know
that dude you know what I'm saying he'
get you in that Lurch he would catch you
with his between his chin and his chest
he would [__] snack you like a snake
we were talking about this dude that his
boy Gert was his name and he would just
get you like that bro and he choke you
down he had no arm no arms at all and
he'd fight anybody dude and he would
choke you he would so if you went to
punch him how would he block oh bro he
spin out of it he'd spin he duck he
Dodge the dude had F I mean he just and
would he catch your hand with his neck
huh would he catch your hand Lurch at
you and bro the thing is here was the oh
you know what if he hits you with that
shoulder you're going down yeah part of
it the big move was that choke he would
get he would catch you like this where
would he catch you your hand in your
neck he would catch you neck to
neck that's [__] crazy once he got
you neck to neck Gert you but this whole
family the whole family was [__] he
could choke you out psychos bro brother
had sharpened half of his teeth on one
side of his mouth dude these people
would [__] you up one of the kids was in
a wheelchair just they never taught him
to walk I think I don't even think he
was crippled they just never taught him
to walk and so the other brother would
carry him on his back everywhere like a
backpack dude and didn't even give a
[__] sh like I remember like on the
weekends we they had this this highway
right next to our apartment building I'd
go out there and me and my buddy would
go out there this kid Jeremy sroll and
he was born for deficiency he was born
like a I don't know any way to put it
really was born with a wrist in his neck
kind of he kind of had like a like his
neck could do more than our necks can he
was born of the wrist in his neck I mean
his neck could do more than our necks
can man really yeah and he uh and we go
out on the on Saturday and pull these
dead dogs off this highway and bury them
like cuz count like cuz I grew up I
really feel like I grew up in the Stray
animal belt of Louisiana and they don't
really have this anymore cuz everybody
has pets now but they had a long time
where there was just I felt like
thousands of Strays running around like
Joey Diaz say he got bit by animals I
got jumped by a bunch of cats on my
birthday once dude I'm not even joking
dude and one of them I swear to God some
of them got me on the ground and one of
them came off a [__] rooftop from
next door I swear to God I still
remember a couple of them were getting
me and looking back and see one come
from something in the
air and uh and they had tons of stray
animals where I was from you couldn't
you infuse that in everything you did
wherever you went or if you were going
to bike or play
ball cat and that'll make you feel like
a little [__] too I mean first of all
your dad's dying and now there's cats
jumping you it's just really but anyway
so I was like we used to pull these
bodies off of the interstate and Barry
him off the highway right holy [__]
because dogs were getting hit there I
mean literally they were [__] piling
up
you and I remember one time we find a
bunch of nudie mags in the ground
somebody had HIIT a bunch of you know
pornography in the dirt and I remember
we got down and somebody then had we
realized I'd never seen any sex before
right so somebody
somebody cut out all the pictures of the
actual insertion points in these
magazines there was probably 11
pornography magazines Club some of the
older ones Club finer ones I thought
actually yeah uh
Penthouse um but where the exact penis
and vagina insertion point happened in
every picture somebody cut that out
that's odd and taken it with them I
guess and I don't know if they did it
because they didn't want people to see
that or they wanted to have it all you
know but I remember this weird [__] like
that and that's when I started to
realizing this [__] didn't happen to
everybody like for some reason God put
all this weird [__] in front of me and
so those are the things that I need to
focus on and that's when I started
thinking that I became a little bit more
confident
because I know what I'm talking about I
think we used to fill [__] we used to
have this game where you would fill like
people's two dudes would fill their
mouth with sugar you know and then you
would you you slap each other in the
[__] cheeks but here's the thing
bro it's it's hard to hold a whole bunch
of sugar in your
mouth keep it and keep it all in well
here's the thing it starts dissolving
but you get parts because all your
moisture is going into this thing so
your body starts to dry out so then you
start you're you're basically holding
the sugar uh in your dry mouth at a
certain point man you feel like the
desert how old were you I don't know
like he was a child okay like when I was
like eight like eight yeah like yeah 7 8
11 14 even 14 even and this 18yearold
shi8 11
14 we used to have this [__] girl
who's probably 14 that went shirtless
bro since she was like [__] four four
to 14 shirtless
bro shirtless why was that I don't know
it just their whole family was pretty
much shirtless and they didn't do any
different by the girls man this girl was
shirtless as [__] and we all thought
like damn she's like a long here she's
like the most best looking dude you ever
seen right we thought that till about 11
and then somebody's like that's a girl
man she just go shirtless we're like and
nobody told her to put a shirt on in
school or nothing oh I don't know about
school but uh I never I mean she was in
a children's school I was a little bit
older than her but dude I remember being
in school and uh statistics or something
and it was like it was it was freshman
year in college and the teachers like
statistically speaking there was, 1400
kids in the class he be like two of you
guys will die in car accidents one of
you guys will be a registered sex
offender she was right wasn't she no I
remember standing up and going not it
that's what I said the teacher said that
not it that's good though get the [__]
out not me not me uhuh I can't I mean I
just let the Lord know what I didn't
want some days we get
closer things that we never really
needed promises we never thought keeping
sa I guess it's never
over if we never got a chance to change
our
[Music]
way we get like taka vakka used to be
the kind of vodka that we would drink it
was just like this offbrand in our
region like Todds almost uh yeah
probably like something like that just
like whatever every place had their own
little local brand or whatever and this
this was called taka and so you go get a
fifth of taka or whatever so one time I
pull up by the um gas station and they
had this man and I was thinking oh this
guy will buy some vodka he looks like he
drinks some vodka and it was daytime you
know it's probably maybe 11:00 a.m. so I
I pick it I say hey man will you get us
some liquor he said yeah I said all
right here's the money you got to go in
and get the liquor come back out and get
in the car it was kind of dude you had
to give exact directions too yeah
otherwise otherwise you're going to
deviate from the plan prob buy like some
[__] uh slim gems and a pack
cigarettes Yeah scratch off [__] the
the dice yeah D come out with
shoes um so anyway he gets back in the
car he's got the liquor and that's when
this dude told me he's like you know I'm
the headb button champion of the world
right last thing you want to hear from
I'm talking this guy the only man I've
ever seen yeah he had that thick head oh
this guy's head was probably made by
that shoe maker right he had that kind
of head he had a Sho biger smaller than
Chin's head Chin's head has a dome on
him it was like Chin's head with another
chin head on top of it all forehead oh
yeah but all forehead D it was that Jaa
snowman was like stacking up a couple of
chins heads right this guy had just like
you could see his NE you could hear his
neck if you put your ear up to his neck
you could his his neck would be like man
I'm
tired I'm exhausted
I'm and he was head button people no he
goes I'm driving us off he has the vodka
and all my I want the vodka from him
right he trying to get [__] up and he
goes you know I'm the headb button
champion of the world right and this
dude's homeless okay
so did you say I didn't know there was a
competition for that sir and this before
they had this is way before this is 20
years before Kimbo Slice right and this
man look exactly like Kimbo Slice right
but with a two-story head oh he's black
but white or black but black all right
100% black and he so next thing you know
he goes you know the head button
champion of the world
and you start to see him kind of just
looking at me as I just feel like
suddenly sizing up your Dome yeah
suddenly I'm looking forward driving and
he's looking directly at me right there
is no us we're not going anywhere
anymore he is just in the car with me
and uh and so I P and he goes do you
want he goes do you think you could beat
me and I knew but when he said do you
think anything at that point I'm already
thinking of the cops I'm thinking of my
funeral I'm thinking of dude in the back
get in
there the [__] out but you can't just
get out of a car when you're driving it
and that's one of the issues with cars
is that you have some responsibility to
stay in there and at least pull it over
it's
yours so I start I pull over cuz I'm not
going to get knocked unconscious while
I'm moving forward you know what I'm
saying I'm not a [__] idiot yeah so
this dude he goes you want to know and
he I know he couldn't even hear me
anymore that I'm saying no he's seeing
red oh yeah for him it's game time it's
game time dude yeah I'm saying no in
different ways I'm saying knowing
different languages and you can tell
it's not registering in his head and he
just lines me up right and just hit me
as hard as he could with his [__]
head bro yeah knocked me completely
unconscious only been knocked out twice
in my life once was actually about 3
weeks ago when I fell into the sofa when
I was wrestling with some children the
other time was when this dude the
self-proclaimed headb button champion of
the world [__] put that one hit
sleeper on me bro here's the crazy part
he didn't even touch me with his
hands did he leave the lock at least he
out huh everything was gone dude
everything was gone he's homeless though
that's the champ though that's the champ
how many people can say he got knocked
out by the champ it's kind of an honor
man
yeah my first thought was that dude is
the champ that my first thought that's a
champ right there no doubt that champ
right there you know when I was growing
up we'd go out there to the cwrs out
there to the Civil War reenactments and
we'd get out there and somebody's daddy
would be in it you know and there'd
always be some [__] chicks out there
trying to [__] smash like some of the
generals and [__] but uh that was a big
thing in the South you know the Civil
War reenactments yeah that's crazy it
was huge man I remember we go there have
6 700 people out there reenacting wow
yeah that's crazy get out there people
are eating somebody's got a horn
somebody's [__] coming out there in
the distance drinking Dr Pepper bro
praying H God I miss it one lady I
remember one time I had pretty bad body
gas on a um flight right you were you
were were you letting it out slow bro
there was nothing I could do it was
almost like something it just I don't
know like a ghost was in me and didn't
want to come out all at once and there
was a lady next to me and I kept blaming
it on on a baby you know cuz I had a
baby nearby [__] baby who is this guy
yeah and it's a girl too first I thought
it was a boy then it was a girl baby
then I felt so bad you know there is
something [__] up about blaming that
on a girl baby yeah it's kind of yeah
that's mean but then at one point the
lady was really buying into that it was
this baby creating this scent you know
so she kept looking at the baby yeah and
the the lady was getting so P the lady
next to be getting so pissed at this
[__] baby and then one time brother
there was one she goes oo that one was
warm she
said and I was like God I got to get
some help for myself sometimes when I
have to fart on airplanes I'll get up
and on the way to the bathroom I'll fart
through the
aisle oh my that's one one of my
favorite things to do you when I was
young we used to play this game called
Gay Chicken they called it uh I didn't
name the game but I was you know I I the
game existed and then I then I existed
um was it your uncle was it the neighbor
well the game was you you and a buddy
you'd grab each other's wiener penis
they call it in those days some of you
guys call it penis but uh yeah you grab
it and the first person to get an
erection lost the game right
so it's like arm wrestling for simp it's
the stupidest [__] game no it's not
simple I mean it is did you win did you
ever win or did you lose did you lose a
lot or did you win a lot oh I did real
well one season uh what is the gay
chicken season what does that go from
it's more of a win it's I would say it's
an Autumn game yeah I would say it's
kind of I think I can see it now all the
leaves changing colors and just the two
of you what do you play with neighbors
or the teams no you just got we only had
about seven guys that played in our
little bracket or whatever but they had
you know what's weird you know what's
interesting you have seven guys in your
bracket yet it's a Twan game yeah and so
there's an odd number oh yeah does it
have to be Twan can't you like do it in
a circle oh come on lady
no come on man that's y'all are messed
up y'all that's called Kik what's that
called uh cocking yeah that's a
different that's a no that's uh bucki
bucki I'm not no Circle jerky that's gay
circle jerk look Caroline Caroline is
the one that's it Caroline knows Circle
jerky and the other thing that that I
remember you dude I was in Louisville
one time I came out of a show they had a
big group in a limousine they invited me
to go to Afterparty with them right I
was like I'm only coming if my boy can
come and like who's your boy and I'm
like ledric they had a brother nearby
right wearing this Louis Vuitton jacket
dude probably about 60% homeless right
and they're like that's your boy and I
didn't even talk to this dude right I
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come so I [__] walk over
him looking right in the eyes and I was
like what's up man I'm Dio he's like
s and uh I was like all right dude I
told these people you're my friend you
ever been in a limousine he's like
nuh-uh I was like all right come get in
with us just act like you're my friend
right we're going to a party he's like
all right man so we go in the limo bro
we're in there hot chicks dudes people
[__] L Cedric kept saying we're
friends that's what he kept saying out
loud right [__] not the best actor
bro but did we get to this house party
it's a nice cool [__] party bro I'm
downstairs I'm in the kitchen somebody's
making us a drink I'm talking to
somebody [__] six minutes later right
here [__] somebody scream I hear a
window break right somebody comes
running down they said some dude just
stole like four
purses out of the coat room upstairs and
[__] jumped a
window that would have been me DG and
that was [__] ledric
bro and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and
pissed and some girl was like Furious
cuz all her tampons were in there or
something I remember she got pissed she
was a tough girl she was like one of
those uh what are those people that
slide the thing on the ice she said
curlers Cur she was a curler and but I
was in my head I was like this is the
best [__] night ever I was young man
I was young I didn't want to be on MTV
like I you know I mean I guess I did but
I was just 19 it's not like I was making
any life choices right right and then
the next thing you know I was like oh if
you don't think that I have a talent
well I'm going to do the hardest job in
town and I'm going to do it the best and
that's started to like just get into my
head like you don't think I have talent
well um let's see if I do you
know so so then I just got into stand up
and I always like making people laugh
like I used to do a similar thing when I
was a child at the lunch table we get
some kids who were mentals or a couple
of might have been mentals and couple
kids that were well you know we get
there and sit them to make them drink
milk and then tell jokes and do stuff
and tell one of them just blew milk out
of their face you
know and if you get some straight up
just couple mentals boy some straight up
saw off humans you get them to dude you
get them straight up blow leche out
their Dome
dude that's America right there you know
what I'm
saying and that's when I knew I was like
oh I got some kind of a gift here you
know I almost blew the throat out of
this one
boy almost threw the this almost blew
blew the throat out of this this one boy
named tot to with his name kind of a bad
name too to be mentally
challenged but also easy for to spell
and I'm not joking that's what his
father said and um easy for him to spell
backward and forward same name
[Laughter]
Tot so that's true man this guy's real
his name was
to why are you so laughing at him you
never [__] your pants man let me think
about what happened to me one time oh I
remember one time I got stuck in a
tunnel my car broke down in a tunnel in
uh Pittsburgh and I had to defecate at
extremely and that's French actually for
[__] yeah yeah and I to defecate and uh
so I got in my backseat of my car and
the only like I didn't have any choice
this was like you know was like
something had gotten into my body like a
pink eye had gotten into my stomach and
uh and all the [__] in my body was
coming out of my body you had p in your
stomach yeah it was like hey we need all
the [__] out of here I had gingivitis
once in my stomach did you
really and I got diarrhea from that too
yeah really yeah yeah I don't know how
it got down there and I had to defecated
into a frisbee I have upside down
frisbee was all I had da be real yeah
yeah what and so I'm in this tunnel
there cars whizzing by here's the crazy
thing yeah extremely hard to poop when
cars are going by at 50 60 70 M hour and
Furious too yeah Furious like and also
white people like it was Pittsburgh so
it's Furious white people driving by I
can if other people some certain
ethnicities acting [__] easier when
they're driving by honestly you know
like if a couple of brothers are rolling
by BL some [__] good music I can
[__] blow ass all day into a fris
right no problem I'm part of you know
everything's everybody's you know
everybody seems like there more laate
back yeah yeah but a angry white dude
you know rolling by you know 6 seven
well they would probably call somebody
too huh oh they weren't calling anybody
I mean the only free finger they had
they were waving it out the window at me
they weren't using it to dial the phone
so you [__] on a frisbee a [__] in the
open the now now the yeah not the top
part but the bottom part a frisbee is
basically a cup basically the sides a
plate it's a plate a plate well a a
plate is just a cup that's way let me
get hang on are you a plate is wide wide
wide C no or you pulled over I pulled
yeah I'll pulled over the car I think
honestly had run out of gas you just
[__] on the ground why did you have to
like yeah so it's dark [__] on the
[__] [__] in a tunnel you idiot okay
you should be familiar with tunnels dude
why huh because of Vietnam because
you're going to do that [__] again right
now man [__] bro why why why you oh no
dude you're doing that Nom [__] again
huh bro what n what you thought that I
was digging tunnels and the hoim Min
Trail and trying to attack you people no
I thought you n the fruit juice the
pomegranate fruit juice that's always in
there what
that P yeah no no dude no not pom n bro
I don't believe in Vietnam I don't
believe it in war
H didn't happen dude are you those uh
they never found the boats dude oh right
it's just like slavery they never found
the boats but what do you mean tunnels
though bro so anyway I'm in a tunnel I'm
in a tunnel and there's only two lanes
going each way there's no there's
nowhere to get out in a tunnel like in a
tunnel you know cars are whizzing by and
so I had to get in the back seat and
defecate into this frisbee right and um
and then wait for the cops to come why
you called the cops why the cops come
had to call the cops somebody I well
somebody not somebody I had just [__] in
a frisbee in my car and I
needed help yeah I mean I just realized
that I grew up in like a just a weird
weird place and it's one thing that's
unique to me is my childhood and my
perspective of it you know yeah it it it
will you grew up you grew up in I grew
up in Covington Louisiana in our Town's
famous um Lee Harvey Oswald went to our
Middle School uh pistol pistol Pete
marovic lived and died in our town
really uh two good Shooters that's the
joke that I use off of that um but like
tuland University had their primate
testing facility in our Town that's
where most people worked at right so and
in 1994 like 70 infected monkeys got out
in our town and they literally the
police came to YMCA summer camp and let
the oldest kids leave to help them look
for these monkeys right are you serious
yeah and I remember like like guys they
had guys with like Rebel flags in their
truck I'm like it's not a racial thing
guys this is these are [__] 70 these
are chimpanzees and macaws that are
loose around town you know this isn't a
gang that's moved in you know
uh but I remember me and a couple of
other kids I still remember having a wet
bathing suit on cornering a [__]
chimpanzee outside of a Kenny Rogers
roaster with a police officer and three
other kids like ra you know by this
drive-thru and this [__] fat elf of a
woman honking at us like we're ruining
her you know dream Shake she's buying or
whatever and her [__] cornbread while
we're trying to [__] Save Our Town
from a [__]
who knows what this monkey had from
Planet of the Apes apocalypse yeah maybe
something Walter Reed missed could have
been yellow fever where you get all
those hamers from that's well they breed
them in our town I used to work for this
group they used to sell tattooed
hamsters and guinea pigs after uh they
tattoo them yeah they used to Brand them
with concerts and ra they would say it's
tattoo just to make people not be as sad
about it for what like what did it say
uh 311 Green Day anything like of
different bands that were coming to town
toies swear to God bro to's Acid Bath we
used to truck these HS into the City and
[__] vend them bro because there
wasn't much there wasn't much work in
our town dude you know you had to get
what you can get and they had a man that
bred hamsters and they had a do that
tattoos and they [__] met up and
that's a merger that's big business you
know and they started uh a merger they
started man I got me some 300 Mouse in
my house and [__] and some other gu like
you know what man I'm a pretty good
tattoo artist
the window oh we locked a thi we locked
this uh this big girl in our town we
locked this big girl one time we ate
some acid and we locked this big girl
into a room at this party and uh and we
kept going in there with [__] pots of
[__] warm water [__] pouring it on
I feel bad I feel horrible dude I didn't
look we was kids and we're on acid
dude and then bro you can't tell me the
story when I'm straight you got to tell
me I'm mushrooms you loock the girl I
just remember how old were you I just
remember
probably 16 that's terrible I know but
here's the thing let's say I was 14 that
way it makes it sound not as
bad but look she ate at no she ate acid
with us bro she ate acid with us dude
and what happened was and we kept going
in the room with like these pots of warm
I don't know why we had the pots of warm
water because I think we just were
[__] up dude and we were like poor a
little H her but not like torches she
wasn't in a cage or nothing she was just
you know free range in this room right
what I think she was scared to come out
and one time we went in bro we heard
this loud sound and we went in and I
wonder why she had ran against one of
the walls so hard bro had [__] moved
the entire wall in this house dude huge
girl about two 240 lbs beautiful girl
too the most beautiful biggest girl that
I've ever known oh my God uh beautiful
girl beautiful hair beautiful face large
just large and beautiful but she [__]
got lifted bro mic circuit in La yeah
started doing open mics here like at
Marty's or where like at uh down and
stuff no they had a place over on the
west side of town I lived I was sleeping
under a buddy of mine had a bed and I
was sleeping under his bed for $150 a
month oh wow and sometimes even in his
bed sometimes when he would be out of
town or when he would leave for work I'd
climb up into his bed dude and I've
never been heavily homosexual but I will
say this that there's nothing really
gayer than getting into a man warmth
after he's already left the room you
know and climbing up into his bed a man
you don't even really know that much but
still catching that hit off of his
temperature you
know that's funny it's true man you go
over to somebody's house dude who you
don't know that much when they leave the
room and get the get get out of their
bed you get into their
bed that should make she never told them
that though that should have Make a Man
Out of You fast dude or it
won't but you find out who's who pretty
quick when you're doing stuff like that
you know yeah I remember like my dad but
[__] he let me drop like say as soon
as I was tall enough like 11 years old I
remember being 11 years old and my dad
being like uh hey will you drive me you
know cuz he couldn't turn his neck you
know so like he's like hey will you
drive me and I'm like yeah I'll [__]
drive I'll hit like 510 I a little gross
spurt when I was 11 so next you know I
was driving my dad places dude like I
remember we Dro him at the post office
and he said go around the block and uh I
went around the block and [__] hid
like seven cars bro just [__] SED my
dad had a
like a Delta 88 you know like a just
straight up [__] rig Rider bro